[Music]
in peace out news submitted by Gilly
woman explains herself after she is seen
leaving a toddler on a stranger's front
porch that's horrible
oh wait somebody killed a toddler
no they left the baby on the grass oh
you know what I did to that video let me
see this [ __ ] so the part that went
viral is a doorbell one because there's
two videos on the budget oh there's like
a ring yeah the ring one where's this
one of those videos where you see the
girl walking the dog and the dog just
takes off and a gangster yeah you never
see no no yes so the girl will be like
she's holding her dog and she's like you
katashi just woke up and she's locking
up her [ __ ] like her house and she was
whoa like a big as though the dog see
another little dog yeah either dog or
cat or like a cartoon all right here we
go so the first part is not the part
that went viral just so you guys know
I'm gonna be mr. positive this is what
the world needs
I'll play the mr. positive angle for
this whole video okay the world needs
more optimism and positivity this person
is rich they got four cars that's
exactly I was gonna say right off the
bat there's four cars be grateful for
what you have oh five because there's
one on the parking lot that's the lady
that's yeah this is her car so this is
what we're looking at
she got a she got a baby oh why should
carry just with one arm look wait very
long be grateful that even have arms
okay she's happy hey I gotta go to the
club oh they're sound old I know that
[Music]
that's my stuff
I know she takes up
she literally looks like she was rushing
to the Glovers mile a second my job or
is she dropping the kid off to the
[ __ ] deadbeat dad because they kind
of feel that way right look at Debbie do
you think I'm gonna take her this
[ __ ] punk ass [ __ ] kid God you know
the deadbeat dad was six cars yep yeah I
mean she did choose the right family to
drop it off that they got flow card she
was smiling you know that's why it feels
a little sus I mean I thought that
excuses anything you know responsible
that baby has a strong arm babies have
strong arms like a title one arm oh
really yeah
their met their met at farms no he
doesn't did I do I grab him like that
did he bless talk about a face all the
time I don't see it is better than this
and he's liking this it's better than
the foot oh okay what might be better so
what she actually abandoned me the child
or was she leaving it for like
babysitting so this first went viral it
was reported that she was this mother
that just abandoned her two-year-old kid
on some stranger's porch so someone just
started making this [ __ ] up well that
was the initial assumption so
responsible the Internet to do so that
was the assumption so then they found
out that what happened here was that
this girl her name is Chiara that she
was doing her friend a favor so the
mother of this child is her friend and
she was in the hospital so she told the
mother asked Cara if she can do her a
favor and drop off her two-year-old to
her to his dad's house see that's still
a [ __ ] up way to leave your kid
exactly exactly that the mom
laughing as she was dragging the kid
[Laughter]
while she's in a Texas [ __ ] like she's
about to go clubbing her explanation for
that why she's smiling she's like I just
smile all the time anyone that knows me
and just knows that I always smile even
when I'm angry I smile that's not a good
excuse yeah for sure
so then anyway so then she said that she
followed the GPS and took and that's
where it led her to that house and then
she was on the phone with the mom and
saying like hey there's like five cars
in front of this house and then she
described the cars she was like is this
a house and she was like yeah I just
dropped the kid off at the porch
don't don't interact with the stepmom
because me and her like this is the mom
saying according to Chiara don't
interact with the stepmom because we
have issues or whatever so then what
Chiara said is that when she rang the
doorbell she saw this woman approaching
the door and she was like really halfway
to the door so then that's when she took
off because she thought that that was
the stepmom and she didn't want to like
Kozma she was ready to drop him off like
from the streets the walking because she
was dragging that child I know I'm with
you guys so then she was just saying
that like you know what like Oh cuz she
was like the mom just told me to just
leave the kid that she's like you want
me to just leave your kid here isn't
whether they reacted to that so yeah so
then the dad also what ended up
happening was that dad lives next door
but he was built the wrong house yeah it
was the wrong house and he wasn't home
because as soon as the neighbor found
out that this kid was dropped out there
they called 911 and then the cops went
next door like all the doors and finding
out if this kid belonged to anybody but
because the dad
so because the kid didn't arrive at the
time that they agreed the data soom that
plans changed and so he ended up instead
of calling a few [ __ ] morons in this
story why didn't the [ __ ] is going on
so then the dad took off and that's why
he was at home when the cops were
arraigned or so that was the wrong house
yes so then two people are confirming
that the stupid moronic story is the
same so the dad is saying yeah this is
true and then the friend is just pissed
because he's like every time I see this
video I just get so angry and why'd you
leave the house follow up dude this
kid's gonna grow up to either do coke or
suck a lot of dicks like oh yeah or be a
one-armed gymnast oh that's true the
positivity it'll be really good and
pull-ups on ya on a dick show you guys
this interview with Kara was she's
explaining herself where's the mom I'm
sorry the mom isn't anywhere in this
story because she was and they don't
even I don't know why she was in the
hospital I mean the moms at Massage Envy
there was like a special okay wait that
was her this is the girl that dropped oh
[ __ ] special Mexico yeah yeah she looks
less ratchet than I had thought - yeah
well she's ready for the inner that's
the interview outfit you got a hard
tattoo on her neck dude big
you-know-what glasses about 20/20 vision
take that [ __ ] off do it no lenses yeah
okay you sure you want me to leave your
child on the point why don't you stay at
the door to make sure about the little
boy he's only two years old he could all
the street the door because I see her
coming halfway through the door in
another video just released by the
Sheriff's Department you can see Kiara
dragging royal by his arm from the
courtyard sure looks like it appeared to
be dangling a little bit I was trying to
carry his bed carry him but it looks
like you could hurt him that way
dangling by his arm it was intentionally
on purpose like [ __ ] her I would
never do this why she's so aggressive
and [ __ ] no she wasn't intentionally on
purpose there was intention to have for
going on the interview so she thought
she was gonna clear up
that's the funny part is that hey we
want an interview I'll go clear up the
air she made it work oh she's like when
they hear my story the whole world's
gonna know I know I was trying to
evacuate the premises saying 20-year old
[ __ ] for sure she's saying crackhead
12-year old [ __ ] they're saying that she
could be charged with child and what she
said yeah that kid could have ran on the
street exactly that's what a lot of you
were saying at 20 I don't think I would
have handled a child that way
but I would handle an interview that way
I'll tell you man I'll be [ __ ]
offended like a [ __ ] why I'm
wearing a [ __ ] red t-shirt why you
weren't a [ __ ] red [ __ ] who
her friends are like you don't even like
who the [ __ ] were her friends that said
like you know what that's a good idea
you should get on the [ __ ] to tell
your story well I'm sure she has a one
less friend the mom pressure they're
still friends I don't think they're
friends anymore
I'm almost a hundred percent sure that
mom saw that video of how like if I was
that long you're turning my child like
that but she was just doing a homegirl a
favor though like she's so stupid that
she can't drop off the [ __ ] first and
then get the kid and walk because you
don't have to hold the child is gonna
tell me yeah you could do that too
she didn't want her makeup all [ __ ] up
and her [ __ ] dress pulled that had it
somewhere she was definitely had to do
she was gonna go get some dick or how
you read my mind
oh yeah she don't get that dick yeah
with a poor little boy he was placed on
Tim he was placed temporarily with Child
Protective Services
and but now luckily he's back with his
mom but luckily he's back with his mom I
don't think so he need a new mom dude
what's the difference between that and
trick-or-treating you're just standing
on the front porch for a little bit with
your loved ones that you were taking
away if you're with strangers for like a
whole like I don't know a few days I
don't know
you probably felt more comfortable with
these like stranger families because
they're all more responsible it's called
breakfast but it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] did
to my mom like she had to go to work my
dad wasn't around but she locked me in
the bathroom
water supply true and I had two
brand-new little kittens to play with
too also they left you with the animals
that would have kept me busy for hours
you think there are no door cameras back
there in a bathroom with kittens those
kids are gonna be drawn the [ __ ]
Twitter all day he's gonna [ __ ] throw
them you didn't do any of that stuff no
I mean she's a boy yeah boys play
differently well Tigers also the size of
a 14 year old so well mm a baby all the
time wish they wouldn't leave me the
[ __ ] alone all the time but not attitude
you had a lot of family members
constantly in the house yeah yeah I
remember being home alone a lot me too
it's just the TV the TV and me yeah
that's all it was and no cable to back
then perfect that's the blackest book it
wasn't that bad cuz I was able to
relieve the house do whatever I want
Wendy well I think like my toddler years
I don't remember but I I think I had
family like there was someone yeah but
like an elementary school I remember
coming home and it was like just my
grandma or like no one was there yeah I
remember like six or seven I just had a
hella like independence already I will
just make my rounds turn on the TV a
table or go to the piano play a couple
notes that I don't really know and then
I would just go to the kitchen food and
no food no just make my rounds in a
circle all they go in the back she's
kept not going back to the fridge with
no food yeah
the first eight times you did it you
telling me you never did that sometimes
you get creative you're like [ __ ] I
don't have milk fine so I got soy milk
on my cereal with soy milk and cheese
like then every time you go back you're
hungry and hungry so I'm gonna eat that
[ __ ] and they're like four other rounds
you're like [ __ ] it but it's usually
like vegetables and [ __ ] and you're just
like [ __ ] that's not food yeah it's not
like an empty fridge with baking soda
right I always had food in my house at
least though that's the one thing my mom
always she liked cooking
so my mom always had food and also in
Asia kids are taught independence very
[ __ ] early so like that's at five so
like yeah it's not like a sad thing to
do that you know I don't know that the
little kids in Japan they're like right
in the subway how old are they like five
City train they train me early to just
go out to the store buy them [ __ ] all
that stuff so I mean there's like half
and half it's cool I mean to do that too
you know we should let it do all the
things but like in this country I know
it's getting worse now cuz now like you
could get like arrested for that back in
their parents did that just made us
stronger and [ __ ] like that my kids
driving me around everywhere at the age
of six I give them the keys do daddy
they go to restaurant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you